all right good morning everybody hope
you can give me today
and since it's so early in the morning
let's start with some warm-up questions
so it's not like this have you heard
about this term computational thinking
before you came to this talk today so
please raise your arms if you did it so
that's most of the people here in the
room second question do you think you
have a precise definition of what
computational thinking actually means
please raise your arm if you feel do I
don't see any arms yes so maybe we
should cover this next question do you
think computational thinking is
something fundamentally new innovative
or is it rather something which just get
a new fancy name so that we can make
presentations about it you think there
there is some some innovation in this
please raise your arms if you do yeah
some people do some people still
sleeping so last one or the one warm-up
round do you believe that we should
invest time and effort in thinking about
creating computational thinking
materials is this something like good oh
yeah okay yeah I see many arms here so
okay so - I'm trying to sum this up many
of you have heard about computational
thinking almost none of you have like a
really clear
definition for it but we kind of all
agree it's maybe something new but we
feel that this is something we should
look more into and work on so this is
what I'm going to cover in my
presentation today and so let's start
with a couple definitions I look for it
and actually there's not so much out
there so today I brought one from
Jeannette wing which is the most like
prominent author in this in this field
and she says computational thinking is
taking an approach to solving problems
designing systems and understanding
human behavior that draws on concept
fundamental to computing and a little
like short and more compact is what
Stephen says or how Stephen tries to
define computational thinking as
formulating things with enough clarity
and a systematic enough way that one can
tell computers tell a computer how to do
them and the last one kind of goes in
the same direction when you look at the
definition so at least for me they don't
feel like very like precise are very
clear so I wouldn't disagree with any of
those but I feel they are not like
exactly kind of pointing to the same
thing and in the sense they are very
like broad or one could say like vague
so for example in the in the first one
so this is about solving problems very
abstract term designing systems and
understanding human behavior so that's
covering like a lot of
like fields and areas so what what
exactly is the thing that makes
computational thinking different and
then other approaches and about the the
the definition from from Steven so what
is it that computation of thinking now
it's different than for example
programming isn't programming something
like like formulating things in clear
enough that the computer can handle it
and do the computations and what is a
computer is a human a computer or is a
machine or server algorithm a computer
all right so yeah so did there there is
no I think like commonly accepted
definition for this and so I looked
deeper in some of the articles and
papers about it and I try to identify
like some terms I found a couple of
times and so what was interesting is
like almost all the literature about
computational thinking is related to
education so it's nothing like like the
string of computer science or something
like this so it's always about in or in
the context of Education usually it's
defined as a skill and I think that's
that's actually a good way of thinking
about it I'd see it as one part or one
discipline of problem-solving and so
what we need for this like skill or to
develop this skill is obviously
computers and what are computers
and obviously we need things like
engineering thinking which could be
programming
and also things like mathematical
thinking what I found quite a few times
is the term abstraction I think that's
that's a good point on this is something
we should look more into it and of
course since we are since this is about
problem solving it's also about like
data and real world applications okay so
still there are many many terms and I
don't feel like I know exactly what it
is or how to describe it or how to do it
but still I have the feeling that it's
something useful or something we should
invest more time in and why is that so I
brought this this meme and inter to me
miss I'm I'm kind of irony involved here
so the problem that many educators or
many people identify is that we we teach
students mainly to learn things by hard
to understand repeat and execute
patterns and this is where we spend like
most of the time in in university or
school and what we don't learn so much
is like how to use the method how to
apply them when they make sense and
actually how we solve problems using
them so yeah actually I mean this should
be like the other way around so nowadays
like acquiring knowledge should probably
not be the highest priority in education
and instead problem solving so yes so
this is like this problem solving as
we've seen on the last slide so this is
something that computational
thinking could achieve sew them in in
the next step I'm I'm trying to see
what's what's already out there to to
get an idea of like where is this
education there's new things
computational thinking and I started
looking at very like pure of trying to
look at the most pure forms of
literature and in economics it's
actually like really hard to find a book
which is only about economics and not
using like math programming and you
actually have to go back in time and I
just picked the world of Nations every
economist will know this book and dates
back to the 18th century and so I did
the same for for math and programming
and so these are like the like the first
books of fundamental books some of the
fundamental books in in this field and
nowaday nowadays what we see is kind of
like intersecting of these fields and so
when you look at the intersection of
economics and math what one could call
applied math or applied economics then
this is where most of the current like
textbooks and economics are and one one
example is a very end so every economic
students will probably have seen one of
his books and in in the in the
intersection between economics and
programming so we we find
usually books which are motivated like
so here's some economics and now I
explain how you can do the same with a
computer or how you can do the
computations with a computer instead of
doing it on paper and in the
intersection of like math and
programming of course there there are
also some some examples for books and so
now I mean there's nothing wrong with
all these books so most of them are
great for for specific purposes but
there's there's one one problem which
brings us back to why computational
thinking is something more relevant to
education and so this is when you look
at the economics book usually it assumes
that you have some background or some
taking some classes in math before or
when you look at a applied economics
book so like programming for economists
something like this then you will find
it that some of the like economic
concepts assume to be so what what what
you actually need to do in order to to
understand like the the big picture is
like you need to unless you need to
start at some point and then you are
able to go to a next level and look at a
new like intersection you field and the
question is can we can we go there more
directly or can we can we kind of do it
more efficiently so all in one thing and
so this is this is where I think
computational thinking is
should be or could be and this is like
really the intersection of all the three
fields okay so now like thinking about
this I I haven't found any books
covering exactly this idea of the
intersection of all these fields so I
said okay let's try to create something
and here is a preview so everything you
will see the next minute is still work
in progress so here we go so this is
this is one example I try to create it's
the the title is the tragedy of the
Commons
so in economics we deal with lots of
problems related to the usage and of
over usage of public goods so it's
probably good something like a lake or a
piece of land or street so where you
cannot where where the excess is usually
not restricted and then when many people
start to use it then bad things happen
for example overfishing and when you
when you talk to people with outer
economics background so you sometimes
hear things like okay that's because of
the capitalist they they're taking away
the other the resources and they're only
interested in making profits and they
don't care about the environment and
things like this and then I mean that
that's fair that some people have this
have this impression but then one should
ask like why why are people doing this
they kind of like stupid in the sense
that they are exploiting all the
resources without knowing that they are
destroying the planet or this this
public good and cannot benefit from it
in the in the future and so this is
really somehow like like a very relevant
problem in economics and so here is how
I started this and it all starts with
with the lake and I develop like a very
very like yeah Ross sketch of how this
lake works so I start with an initial
population of fish in the lake and I
introduce a reproduction rate and then
we look at okay so how is this growing
how's the fish population growing in
this lake and once we have this now we
can see or we can introduce some natural
limits so the population is not growing
to infinity so there are some some
boundaries given by nature and so then
we have like a very raw model of how the
fish population the leg works only by
having this this limit and the
reproduction rate and now we're going to
introduce fishermen so we start with one
fisherman fishing at the lake and we
make some assumptions on on the catch
and the days this fisherman's working at
this lake and so what we can compute is
like fish harvest so the amount of fish
he takes per year okay so after that now
we can build on
this raw model of the lake and now we
see what happens when the fisherman is
at the lake and so we have the the fish
population and like the harvest which
obviously the fish who are taken out of
the lake cannot reproduce so this has
some or imply some dynamics and now only
but with a few more things we can
already build like a very sophisticated
model so now we can kind of like explore
this ecological system by having the the
initial fish endowment and reproduction
rate and the fisherman and the catch as
dynamic variables in this in this and
the interesting thing is economists
would usually look at marginal rates and
elasticity's and things like this but
with such a like simple model you can
already see that like you can get the
intuition so when you when you increase
the the fisherman the number of
fishermen a little bit so it totally
kind of like kills the fish population
so then something like overfishing would
happen ok so another another really nice
I think like intuitive example is when
there's 1 million fish at a lake at the
reproduction rate of 5 we can take out
800,000 so 80 percent per year and what
happens if we just take one more fish
per year so shouldn't make much of a
difference and that's actually true for
the first five years but then as we see
if we keep on doing this after nine
years
the lake is completely empty over fished
so all right so this is this is this
first part is really like to understand
the ecosystem and now we keep adding
more like economics so now we have what
what happens when they are more
fishermen so this is what economists
call like a best response so when when
they're more fishermen then it get it's
getting harder to to catch fish and so
the decision on how many days per year a
fisherman should go fishing then depends
on the decisions other fishermen make
okay so we introduce this and then just
add a few dollar amounts prices for
fishes and costs for the boat and and
gas and stuff and so we can easily see
that when we have one fisherman and
obviously he has the highest profit and
as we have more fisherman then the
profit goes down and what what is
interesting here to understand the
problem of overfishing is that people
wouldn't stop fishing at the moment they
they make like negative profits so
whenever there are fixed cost involved
this one economist caught some costs in
in this context then people would keep
fishing even when they make losses at
the end of the year and what happens is
that there's no natural regulation so
people tend to over fish a lake okay and
now what can we do about it
so there there are many ways of
government regulations in this respect
so I upon the other
seven here and and then what economist
will do is what look at what is an ideal
situation and compare this social
optimum to the consequences are like the
the scenarios of different regulations
and this is actually what I compared at
the end doesn't look very pretty it but
at the end it will go like this
so you have seven different regulation
you can think of like policies and then
you have certain like cost cost
components and then you can relatively
assign like the size of the cost and you
will see like that
these options are these regulation
policies different or community or the
different okay so this this was the
example and just 10 seconds to to wrap
this up it's been like really really
tough to to to work on this so it it
doesn't look like that standard as much
out there but I already worked on this
over for quite a time and it's it's
really it's it really takes some time
it's a release some something like
different to create this new type of
content and yeah here the the the five
takeaways from for my work so far so we
should use this abstraction rather than
then defining like levels of audiences
like this is bachelor's or this is like
start starting levels so we should we
should focus on real-world problems and
and tell the stories and like step away
from this traditional education
approaches we should not focus on
teaching math and teaching methods
computational methods because the books
already out there and we should try to
fascinate people and don't try to to
acquire knowledge or findings and use
interactivity as much as possible thank
you
[Applause]